the verdict came at the end of a
frenetic eight-hour trial
and it wasn't the one harry maguire or
his family were hoping for
uh alan you must be disappointed with
how that's gone
his dad allen leaving court dejected
after the manchester united captain was
found guilty
of assault resisting arrest repeated
verbal abuse
and repeated attempts of bribery allen's
other son joe mcguire was also found
guilty of assault
verbal abuse and repeated attempts of
bribery
maguire wasn't in court for his trial
instead
alan filed past photographers at the
start of proceedings
and watched from the front row the
witnesses came
thick and fast and as the day progressed
it didn't look good for harry maguire
the prosecution claimed that while he
was under arrest harry maguire said
do you know who i am i'm the captain of
manchester united
i'm very rich i can give you money i can
pay you
please let us go police claimed they
intervened in a scuffle
they said the english men did not calm
down one of the defendants said
f the police one of the defendants
punched an officer
mcguire's defense said the incident
started when two albanian men
approached his sister daisy they said
they injected her with something and she
immediately fainted
harry maguire's lawyers didn't even want
this case to go ahead today they called
for an adjournment
they then called for the prosecution
witnesses to be thrown out of court
the judge denied that it's been
incredibly heated
at one point the judge slamming his hand
on the desk
as he tried to bring some sense of order
to the court
maguire's childhood friend ashton morley
paced the corridors nervously as he
waited to be called to the stand
he said the group didn't know the
plainclothes officers were police
he said they were afraid of being robbed
or kidnapped
but the judge wasn't convinced and
handed harry maguire a 21-month and
10-day
suspended prison sentence the
prosecution were victorious
but still angry a sportsman's like
conduct is if you've done something
wrong which can happen we understand
that
you are you say you're sorry and you ask
for an apology
till today we have not heard a single
apology from his party
and this is what angry ass more than
everything else
it may have been going downhill in
greece but back home harry maguire was
given full backing by gareth southgate
the england manager selecting the
defender for his upcoming nations league
squad
while the trial was still ongoing
but with the verdict came a u-turn
suddenly maguire was dropped
perhaps the biggest punishment of all
there was no doubt about who the losing
side was here
maguire's defense lawyer tight-lipped
but clearly
frustrated alexis can we just have a
quick word
did you feel hard done by it seemed to
travel very quickly that case
harry maguire says he will appeal this
decision
but the damage to his reputation is
likely to stay with
him long after this legal battle ends
martha kellner
sky news cyros